hello everyone and welcome to a game so
many of you have already requested it's
pragananda versus jordan fun forest and
it's a game from the penultimate round
of the charity cup that is currently
being played uh it's a brilliant game a
very short one and you guys will enjoy
it most of you have probably already
seen it and you only came here to write
in the comments how you thoroughly
enjoyed it and what a great experience
it was but for those of you who still
haven't seen it you guys will enjoy it
even more or maybe the ones who have
seen it will enjoy it even more i have
no idea or or any way of knowing such
things but i'm sure everyone will enjoy
it so let's dive straight into it uh
prague with the white pieces opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 uh c for g6
knights to c3 and d5 so fun forest goes
for the groomfield defense and now not
going for the exchange variation is this
pretty much uh the only variation we see
uh when we show the groomfield in top
level chess but rather knight to f3 the
three nights variation and this can get
very very interesting very very soon so
bishop to g7 uh e3 so notice that there
is no exchange on d5 and there will be
no kicking of the knight so completely
different stuff uh we have castles c
captures knight captures and now bishop
to c4 this is how we challenge the
knight so we kind of do kick it away but
not with the e4 push knight to b6
attacking the bishop on c4 bishop to b3
and now striking against prague center
with c5
prague castles this is still all very
standard stuff both of them notice c
captures on d4 and e captures on d4 so
now prague has the isolated d-pawn
and he will of course try to make the
best of it we have knight to c6 and now
uh advancing the path not the best pawn
the isolated spawn uh to d5 uh knights
to a5 attacking the bishop and now comes
uh h3 preventing the bishop from being
developed to g4 if you play the
automatic bishop to c2 and kind of want
to keep the bishop paired then we then
we happily give up the dark square
bishop here for captures captures and
queen captures we just grab a pawn uh
rune white's pawn structure completely
and black would be better here it can
still be very tricky it's a rapid game
of course there are a lot of dark square
weaknesses here
around the black king but um
it doesn't seem like it will be enough
but for rap again maybe it could be so
instead we have h3 and now comes rook to
e8 uh here the the the actual there is
just capturing the bishop if you want to
go for this captures captures now bishop
captures on c3 but now it's uh it is a
little bit different for example b
captures on c3 queen captures now we can
play bishop to d2 uh hide the queen on
c2 play c for put the bishop on c3 so
again uh it will be very very tricky to
play this for black so jordan doesn't
want to play this against prague uh he
has already seen how uh how strong
progress is in these extremely
complicated positions and he plays rook
to e8 we have rook to e1 and now bishop
to f5 so nicely developing not
doing anything weird and g4 now
challenging the bishop on f5 and now we
reach the position that was reached
already in a match in 2018 between david
navarro and wei yi uh that ended in a
draw and in that game bishop to d7 was
played but here we have knight captures
on b3 and it is now as of move 14 that
we have a completely new game uh so
let's see how prague uh
uh replies here so you could capture
with the queen or with the pawn he
captures with the pawn to give the rook
the the semi-open a file with bishop
back to d7 as the bishop on f5 is still
hanging and now bishop to g5 nicely
pinning that e pawn so d6 will always be
a tricky tricky move to counter and you
can't really push the pawn because the
queen would hang so h6 we have to get
rid of that bishop bishop h for g5
bishop back to g3 and now uh you could
continue this game in many different
ways uh probably the safest one is e6 so
we have to challenge this pawn somehow
but that means giving prague with the
past the d pawn now bishop c6 we put our
bishop on this diagonal
and we uh hope that this pawn will not
be too strong to to win the game for
white and
in all uh you know fairness it should be
should be okay for black but here jordan
played the very aggressive f5 and this
is where things get extremely
interesting so now uh probably of course
you don't want to wait for f4 to be
played to completely lock your bishop
out of the game so you either play
bishop to e5 right away or the way
prague will play that e captures on f5
sorry g captures on f5 bishop captures
and bishop to e5 now uh here we have
bishop captures an h3 now capturing the
dark square bishop here would be a
little bit safer but this uh well this
simply want to do here prague captures
on g7 king captures now queen to d4
check the white king is also very very
open here we only have the the f1
defending the white king but white has
the initiative here and the problem is
if you move the king let's say king h7
uh the problem is there are moves like
queen to d3 check notice that the bishop
on h3 isn't very safe and let's say king
g795 and now you are threatening uh this
queen g6 check followed by queen uh
knight to f7 checkmate or a queen to f7
checkmate depending on what the the
black king plays uh but also if this is
prevented you can just pick up the free
bishop on h3 so this would be completely
winning for prague so e5 is played
trying to open up some defensive lines
for for the rook and queen
rook captures on e5 now threatening all
sorts of nasty discoveries and now comes
king the g8 stepping out of the
uh out of the nasty discovery area and
now queen to e4 going after that g6
square and you know once your queen hits
that g6 square you are never losing this
game you are 99 winning the game but you
are never losing it so that this is
played without question king to g7
preventing this and now comes the move i
probably will put in the thumbnail uh
it's a move that completely shatters
black's defenses and it's a move that
prague played fairly quickly uh rook
captures on a7 just brilliant brilliant
stuff uh getting one of the defenders of
the e8 rook away from the back rank and
there's just no way no good way to
counter this if you try to trade on e5
first we can even pick up the b7 pawn
with check uh once knight knight blocks
we can play knight captures on e5 now
we're threatening to capture here we're
threatening queen to g6 this is uh insta
resign so after rook captures on a7 uh
jordan tries to rook captures on a7 but
now uh we are not defending the e8 rooks
efficiently so rook captures on e8 queen
to d6 and now queen to d for check
trying to bring the queen over to the h8
square king to f7 and queen to h8 now uh
preparing to check me to the black king
so rook to a1 with check but not just
blocking knights the a1 knights the e1
and there is no good way for black to
continue this uh uh
however there is one way that will force
prague to be very very creative in order
to win this game so king the g6
rook the g8 with check came to h5 and
now it looks very very scary for black
however there is only one move that wins
the game for white all the other moves
lose the game so feel free to pause the
video and win the game for prague while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the royal
fork and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show of course it is rook
captures and g5 we can even do it in
slow motion i know you guys really
enjoyed that rook captures on g5 and uh
you could resign here but jordan plays a
few more moves of course the pawn cannot
capture the pawn is pinned and if the
king captures then comes the royal fork
knight the e4 check and black can resign
this so jordan of course played king to
h4 still hoping to somehow save the game
but now comes queen to d for check and
now you either get checkmated you have
to put something in front of the king or
you finally captured that rook and this
is actually what happened knight the e
for wit check uh andy was in this
position during the royal fork that
jordan fought forest resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
we can play a few more moves just to
show you how how hopeless it is let's
say king h5 we capture the queen and yes
you do get to capture the knight on e1
with check but after king h2 the bishop
is hanging the knight is hanging there
there is no compensation here so of
course your denotes this after knight e4
check he resigned in in a beautiful
beautiful position uh it would be it
would be an even greater uh you know
move to to resign on rook captures on g5
but i guess allowing the royal fork was
also very aesthetically pleasing so we
will allow it
uh so yeah that's the game thank you uh
for recommending it uh like a hundred
times um i'm probably i'm sure i would
have uh seen the game as i'm following
the event myself but it is always nicer
when i get so many suggestions at once
even while the game is still being
played uh so uh really brilliant stuff
by prague going for that uh well a line
that we don't see every day going for
the three nights variation against the
groomfeld playing extremely aggressively
then jordan played that f5 move which
kind of opened up the position a bit too
much and prague just made everything
explode it's a brilliant game beautiful
to see beautiful to re-watch uh be sure
to show it to your friends at the bar in
the library and well that's it hope you
guys enjoyed this one uh so yeah i would
like to thank aboard blueberry friends
uh nft yeah
niletto stefan harris berger michael
colbert and uh jay langdon consulting
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the charity cup uh until it
ends thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day